[Music]
matt joins us up next in nashville
tennessee right down the road matt
welcome to the show
hey george how's it going great how are
you
going pretty good man i
appreciate you taking my call thank you
it's an honor happy to do it what's
going on with you um
well so just real quick i wanted to ask
i i'm pretty sure i already know the
answer i guess just more so looking for
affirmation i guess but i got plenty of
that
my wife and i are
are doing the baby steps together
i went through financial peace
university
myself about three maybe four years ago
got myself out of debt 100 percent
awesome
started walking through it a second time
with my wife
when we met in 2020
and sushi has paid off uh a very
considerable amount of debt since then
but we're down to uh down to the last
one
so definitely see the light shining in
our face at the end of the tunnel um
she her last debt is uh some student
loans um
less than 16 000 i think maybe 15 and
some change i think we're looking at
okay so we've got the savings to pay it
off but that would cut our savings
almost in half
and i know with times of inflation like
you were just talking about you know
uh god forbid if something were to
happen with when one of our jobs or
something you know
um
that you know
um that savings
uh wouldn't carry us through as much
today as it would have a year maybe two
years ago so i'm kind of i'm a little
hesitant because it's a little scary uh
cutting our savings in half but then
again we would be 100 debt free
so i just wanted to hear your thoughts
on that yeah i understand matt that's a
tough one because right now you see
security in your savings account and i
see insecurity with these student loans
still around your necks and so the way i
look at it is this
that that money already has a name and
it's not yours right now it's navient
it's sallie mae it's whoever you owe
this student loan money to and so when
you deplete that savings account that's
not forever because remember you now
have freed up a student loan payment and
so now we can start saving up real quick
to get our fully funded emergency fund
in place which is actually going to give
you the security you're looking for
so how much do you have in savings
so
we have two savings
i have we have a house fund from the
sale of her house last year
there's a just shy of 80
k in that and then we have
we have a uh an emergency savings that
we've saved up and there's about 30 and
some change in that
so you have 110 000 in liquid cash
and you're calling me over a fifteen
thousand dollar student loan debt that
you want to keep around i mean are you
hearing yourself yes
yes sir i am
okay well the good news is this is a
good problem to have because the student
loans are gone today and you still have
95 000
does that not give you security
it does uh i mean
we were saving 86 of that to uh i'm
sorry we were saving a large chunk of
that toward down payment on a new house
but whenever
whenever the market quits being stupid
we uh
we're actively looking with our realtor
right now but um we're constantly being
outbid by people coming over from
different parts of the country and now
bidding us locals so that's the
nashville we
we've kind of decided just to hold off
on looking for a house right now sit
tight we're in a we're in a very nice
apartment in a very safe neighborhood
right now
so we're not in a position where we have
to make a hasty desperate decision so
we're just going to sit tight on that
for the next year or so
and continue to build on that house fund
perfect so if you paid off the loans
today you have 95 000 you keep stacking
money on top of that of course uh part
of that's your emergency fund so we're
leaving that alone but that puts you in
3b today if you paid it off which means
you're saving up for that down payment
you'll have a six-figure down payment i
assume that's at least 10 of whatever
you're looking at buying right 20
probably
uh it'd be between 25 and 30
given our max budget this is a great
place to be matt i have no hesitation in
paying off these loans today
okay even with no interest recruiting or
whatever it is
yeah absolutely man good luck come do
your debt-free scream that'll be a fun
one